TRUMP ADMINISTRATION AND
DEMOCRATIC GOVERNOR YOU ARE
NOW COMPLICIT AS SOME OF THE
GRASSROOTS WOULD SEE IT
GILLIAN, THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME.
>> THANKS, PETE.
>> Pete: JOINING US IS DAN
SCREEN SLAW A REPUBLICAN
RUNNING FOR CONGRESS IN
BORDER DISTRICT IN TEXAS.
IS HE A FORMER DECORATED
SEAL.
ALAN MOORE IMMIGRATION
ATTORNEY HERE TO DEBATE.
COMMANDERS, I WILL START
WITH YOU.
WE HAVE A SITUATION HERE
WHERE THE PRESIDENT SEES AN
EMINENT NATIONAL SECURITY
THREAT.
CONGRESS WILL NOT DELIVER ON
THE FUNDING FOR THE BORDER
WALL.
SEND THE TROOPS.
WE KNOW THERE ARE
LIMITATIONS WHAT THEY CAN DO
AT THE BORDER.
IS THIS AN IMPORTANT STEP
AND WILL IT HELP STEM THE
TIED?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
IS HE MAKING GOOD ON PROM
MIST TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
HE WITHIN
HE RITHIN
HE RANHIN
HE RAN ON A BORDER WALL.
THAT WALL WILL HAVE TO BE
ENFORCED BY NATIONAL GUARD.
WE HAVE A LONG HISTORY OF
THIS IN TEXAS.
FRANKLY WE HAVE BEEN FOOTING
THE BILL.
WE ARE ON THE FRONT LINE.
WE REALIZE THIS IS A
NATIONAL SECURITY ISSUE.
WE SPEND OUR OWN MONEY TO
ACTUALLY PUT DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC SAFETY TROOPS ON THE
GROUND TO HELP ASSIST LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
WE ALSO PUT NATIONAL
GUARDSMEN ON THE FIELD
REGULARLY.
IT'S NOTHING NEW TO US.
IT'S FRANKLY TIME FOR THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO HELP
OUT.
>> Pete: DAN CRENSHAW JUST
MENTION YOU HAD THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC SAFETY
IN TEXAS.
BASED ON THEIR STATISTICS
FROM 2011 TO 2012, 245,000
ILLEGALS HAVE BEEN ARRESTED
IN TEXAS ALONE.
1,000 -- OVER 1,000
HOMICIDES.
77,000 ARRESTS, ASSAULT
ARRESTS.
78 DRUG CRAZIES.
THESE OF ILLEGAL ALIENS IN
TEXAS ALONE ARRESTS BETWEEN
2011 AND 2018.
YET, BASTED ON SOME OF THE
COMMITTEE TEAR I HAVE
COMMENTEE TEAR I HAVE
COMMENTAE TEAR I HAVE
COMMENTARYTEAR I HAVE
COMMENTARY WAR I HAVE
COMMENTARY WER I HAVE
COMMENTARY WE DI HAVE
COMMENTARY WE DO HAVE
COMMENTARY WE DO NAVE
COMMENTARY WE DO NOTE
COMMENTARY WE DO NOT.
IS IT TIME TO AADDRESS IT.
>> THERE ARE WAYS TO ADDRESS
THE IMMIGRATION CRISIS.
ACTUALLY THE BORDER WALL AND
ACTUALLY AN INDIVIDUAL WALL
AND A HUMAN WALL IS NOT THE
WAY TO BEST ADDRESS THE
ISSUE.
TO TO SHOW THIS IS A MAN
MADE CRISIS.
12 MONTHS INTO THE
ADMINISTRATION ALL OF A
SUDDEN AFTER THE IF A THERE
WAS A DACA DEAL RAN AWAY
FROM.
AND DEPLOY PEOPLE.
IT SOUNDS LIKE TO ME TEXAS
HAS IT UNDER CONTROL FOR THE
STATE OF TEXAS.
THAT'S REALLY WHAT THE
CONCERN IS RIGHT NOW.
LOOK AT FEDERALISM AND WHAT
THE NATIONAL GUARD IS IN
PLACE TO DO.
THEY PUT THESE INDIVIDUALS
IN PLACE TO DO AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL.
WHY SHOULD THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SORT OF STEP IN.
>> WHY NOT NOW.
IS IMMIGRATION NOT A FEDERAL
ISSUE?
TEXAS MAY HAVE STEPPED UP TO
DO ITS PART.
ULTIMATELY 24 IS SOMETHING
THAT EFFECTS ALL OF US U
WHAT THE KNOW.
GUDMUNDSSON BE DOING WHY NOT
NOW IF.
>> THERE IS NO WAY TO PUT
HUMAN NUT WAY OF STANDING AT
THE BORDER.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
NATIONAL GUARD OFFICERS,
THEY ARE PART OF COMMUNITY.
THEY ARE FIREMEN AND POLICE
OFFICERS AND TEACHERS THAT
ARE PART OF COMMUNITIES THAT
KEEP THEM STRONG AND KEEP
THEM SAFE.
YOU ARE REMOVING PEOPLE FROM
COMMUNITIES AND PUTTING THEM
AT THE BORDER FOR A THREAT
THAT DOESN'T EXIST.
FOR WHAT REASON WHAT?
THERE IS NO NUMBERS, NO
CARAVAN.
SHOW ME THE THAT ITS IT
PARTICULARS.
>> Pete: A THREAT THAT
DOESN'T EXIST.
DAN, I WILL GO WHAT YOUS WHAT YU
DAN, I WILL GO WHAT YOUS WHAT YS
WITH WELL.
>> 2011 TO 2018 ARRESTED IN
TEXAS ALONE.
WE ARE TALKING HOMICIDES,
ASSAULTS, DRUGS, SEXUAL
ASSAULT OVER 10,000 FOR
WEAPONS.
>> IF NOT HUMANS THEN A WALL
HOW DO WE GET OUR ARMS
AROUND THIS?
AND IS IT NOT A NATIONAL
SECURITY ISSUE?
HAVE YOU AN INVASION
PROBLEM.
>> IT'S A NATIONAL POLICY
ISSUE.
>> HE DID SAY ONE THING THAT
WAS ABSOLUTELY CORRECT WHICH
IS THAT WE WAITED TOO LONG.
WE SHOULD HAVE DONE THIS
BEFORE.
WE SHOULD HAVE DONE THIS A
LONG TIME AGO.
FRANKLY IT HAS BEEN DONE
BEFORE.
THE LEFT IS LOSING THEIR
MINDS ABOUT THIS BUT IT WAS
DONE BY OBAMA IN #BG 10,
BUSH IN 2006.
IS HE RIGHT WE HAVE DO